so what do you see coming down the pike
now and again uh you get calls from uh
very high-end organizations all the time
trying to get your crystal ball uh like
what are you seeing and hearing
um has chat EPT changed a lot of
people's minds yeah I think it's had an
extraordinary impact I mean I I don't
think there's any other
technology I can think of that in such a
small amount of time so rapidly has
really just caught the imagination of
the public and I think what's happened
is people have really looked at and they
said wow you know AI is really here and
to some extent that's true
um you know and yet the other side of
that is I think it's also it's also
overhyped a lot of people are looking at
at gpt4 GPT and they're thinking this is
the emergence of of AGI right human
level Ai and I'm personally skeptical of
that
um I think it's an extraordinarily
powerful tool that's going to be used in
many many different ways
um but what it amounts to is a system
that can write or or speak but it can't
really think you know and there's a big
difference there uh
and you know some people do believe that
you know by the time you get to gbt 7 or
8 or 15 that this will evolve into
a true thinking system and maybe that's
true but I think there's a lot more
stuff that needs to be put in there um
you know my view on this is that
intelligence probably requires
manipulating the world in some way I
mean you think of a human baby almost
from the moment they're born they begin
to reach out and touch things and and
interact with their environment
and this is how they learn this is what
they they this is how people achieve
what we think of as common sense right
which is
basically our under understanding of the
world the physics of the world you know
um and most of that is Unwritten and yet
with with
these GPT systems essentially what
you're talking about is a system that is
trying to become intelligent just by
reading right that's all it does is it
these large language models it
assimilates words right written words
and as a result of that it becomes
really powerful at generating written
material but can you become intelligent
can you really understand the world just
by reading well I I tell my kids the
answer is yes but uh in terms of Common
Sense we make a lot of assumptions about
what what we understand it's not you
know you know otherwise every book would
be 10 000 pages long if you had to
explain everything in detail right we we
make a lot of assumptions in terms of
common sense right and I don't know how
chat gbt can pick that up and how it can
really build a a true model of the world
and become intelligent also AGI which
you referred to is artificial general
intelligence where you have a thinking
machine and I agree with you that uh
this thing may not actually be sentient
uh in that way but I also think that
it's not going to make a difference for
a lot of practical purposes
um where if it can write a press release
or
an investment analysis or a newspaper
article uh in seconds
or a college paper I mean you know like
what what the heck does that mean I
think that's exactly right and that's
the point I've been trying to be make
I've tried many times to make for a long
time is that
in terms of automating many jobs
probably most jobs you don't need human
level intelligence right because most
people are not
drawing on General human level
intelligence in most of what they do
most people are doing predictable
routine things that that you know
doesn't really require human level
intelligence um some aspects of their
jobs do but again what we're going to
see is all the routine stuff is going to
get automated and the only thing that's
going to be left is that that stuff that
really does require human level
intelligence and then that's going to
result in fewer jobs and that also I
think explains why progress in some
areas like for example self-driving cars
has not been as rapid as as everyone
predicted and I think part of the reason
that it turns out that driving a car in
say New York City in traffic with
pedestrians and bicyclists and all of
that it probably does require something
at least pretty close to human level
intelligence in order to do that to deal
with that that kind of a environment
that is so unpredictable and that's why
um the ironic thing is that you know the
taxi driver isn't yet threatened but the
the consultant at Bain or McKinsey that
you know has has a Harvard MBA degree
might be threatened right
glad you're enjoying the podcast if you
really like it hit subscribe and then
YouTube will notify you every time we
have a bang-up new guest thank you